on September 29th three World titles are
on the line in three different sports
one Epic night for women's martial arts
that phantix is something else ham is a
beast
two world champion it's inside it's
Insanity Here Comes Kelly that is Shia
awesomeness
one fight night 14. stamp vs Ham on
Prime video
now Brandon
all the way from New York I told you I
wanna I wanna jump on the plane and come
out to Calabasas just for for my dumbass
all the way from New York and then you
gotta fly from here are you going
straight from here to Singapore no I'm
going back home going to Singapore on
Sunday night yeah because you got a big
fight next Saturday yeah big fight like
he uh would be next Saturday for me busy
Friday for you Friday for me okay gotcha
Saturday morning and for those that
don't know this is Daniel Kelly one of
the
most
talented badasses on the planet
especially at 115 pounds in the women's
division yeah forget women's division
just overall leglock specialist
face of one Championship you're actually
competing for a world championship in
Jiu Jitsu on the one platform which is a
big deal very big deal especially you
look at the progression of Jiu Jitsu and
as far it's come like if you would tell
me five years ago they'd have let alone
a you know a male and Mikey mushumashi
competing for a world championship on
major Network TV on Amazon let alone a
woman at 115 pounds I'm like you're
crazy but look how far it's come yeah um
I'm actually I competed for one a year
ago as like the first women's grappling
match and then this will be the first
women's title for 115. it's it's called
Adam Lee so like Adam Lee in the US it's
it's considered like 105 but for uh one
Championship it's like 105 to 115. so
yeah it's it's pretty exciting it's
pretty exciting I think it's cool too
because
Jiu Jitsu you know now it's I mean
you're a professional Jiu Jitsu player
yeah that's what you are like how dope
is that like you can make a living doing
Jiu Jitsu yeah because when I started I
started like when I was like 10 and um
10. yeah oh is it karate first if you
want to count nine years old but from
Karate to jiu jitsu
um when I started like women Jiu Jitsu
it's about nmma fighting wasn't known it
wasn't popular it was hard even for
women to get fights like you're probably
just trading with a bunch of boys I
assume yeah majority yeah I uh
especially coming from like a Philly
school like that was my first school I
was like you know imagine a 10 11 year
old me going against kids who are like
16 17 like there was barely any girls in
my class that's why you sound good yeah
I had to learn pretty early at a young
age some rough some rough learning
lessons against dudes oh yeah and like
when I started to get older like 16
years old 17 then we'll go against guys
who like had to prove a point it was
yeah Philly's pretty brutal yeah guys in
general can be brutal yeah but so I
think what's fascinating is now you know
I have two young boys if they want to
make a living Jutsu it's actual
possibility now like with Mikey
mushumesha we had him uh in studio and
he's like I don't have to do anything
else because I was like hold on if
you're tied to one Championship you
can't compete in all these other you
know ibjff all that stuff you can't
compete and you know Eddie Bravo's
information I think that's pretty cool
like just for me because I can focus on
one person that's what I'm saying it's
great you know if I compete every other
month or weekend my opponents in my
bracket could study me or their coaches
and I could get injured more whereas you
know for this one especially all my
focus is on one person and my training's
been better than usual it's like you're
a professional yeah
Mikey was like yeah you are yeah you
mean you're getting paid and you're
professional so you don't have to fly
around yeah all over the United States
and compete right people like you know
if it was now if it was like back in
like 2008 or 2010 you have to go ship to
MMA to make money or get like get stuff
or yeah that's why that's why I think
it's good too because like Gordon Ryan's
talk about Mikey mushuma she's talked
about you know these are guys who make
seven-figure livings doing just Jiu
Jitsu and like I don't do MMA I'm like
why yeah why would you want to do that I
don't get it yeah eventually but I mean
for now like I love what I do so I just
want to focus on Jiu Jitsu yeah whenever
I hear the these top dogs and jits who
go ah you know I want to trickle over to
MMA I'm like back again to your point
five years ago yeah it makes sense you
need the money but now if you especially
for example like back then you know my
old coach like at the time he didn't
want me to do MMA
um but I wanted to do event like uh
eventually just because I was getting
bullied but he was just saying that's at
the time you know if I want to do MMA
I'm not gonna get far you know women's
MMA isn't going to be popular unless
you're like in Strike Force that's when
like or before Strike Force I think Gina
Carano was like coming out do you know
what vacant Strike Force yeah yeah you
had uh junior
Cyborg and then Rhonda Miesha Tate and
strike force synopsy that you'll see uh
bought them and kind of took over so but
now they're I mean the girls are kicking
ass oh yeah they're yeah the talent like
you can just tell too like if you watch
like a lot of the fights like the uh
their techniques and everything has like
progressed whereas like back then like I
feel like they're catching up with the
guys and you know the guys are like so
like years ahead of the girls yeah I'd
say girls certain ones not in general
I'd say as a whole probably five years
behind five to eight years behind the
the men as far as you know one through
fifteen but there's like the top five in
every division in the UFC like
chefchenko Grosso like rose andrage uh
Cortez Tracy Cortez like those girls are
just as talented like their techniques
are very similar to the to the dudes
yeah which is impressive but yeah for
the most part you know some of the
women's divisions still in leather
helmets of this is football you know
like they're just like either their
Specialist or they don't have a complete
kind of
um repertoire as far as the guys go but
they're they're getting there like
there's some monsters yeah I mean
recently too like I mean I'm a Grappler
so I still study Jiu Jitsu matches but I
like I enjoy watching like MMA fights
and especially the girls but you can
just tell at least like the ones I
trained with you can just tell like
who's like kind of behind or who's like
ahead you know just like the top women's
top 10 or top five if you put like a
number nine with a number like number
four sometimes the number nine is like
way ahead of the number four like that's
just how you know up and down women's
you know but you've also competed
against some big UFC names as well yeah
and I I trained with some yeah yeah so
but again I don't think and for the
common like fan of Jutsu or UFC I don't
think they realize like when you have a
Jujitsu specialist when it's like all
you do like we used to have brelo uh
estima come in uh haja Gracie
um the bushesha would come in and roll
with us and and we're a lot of us are
black belts we're like oh dude how much
different can be I mean you just tie us
in knots you know it hurts it feels
different though like if you have a good
balance of striking and grappling if you
know how to wrestle and music age I feel
like if it's straight MMA yeah we can do
our thing but when it's if there's
actually if it's straight BJJ no ghee
even ghee forget about it but if it's
straight BJJ and they're like yeah
whatever you want to do I mean like
Gordon Ryan toys with these girls MMA I
mean like this isn't hating on like
don't you Jitsu or anything but you can
just tell like someone most of them
don't know how to use Jiu Jitsu in
fights they know how to like wrestle
because a lot of people a lot of girls
wrestling now is more popular than it
was before so they know how to wrestle
but one gets to the ground you can just
kind of tell you can tell yeah the
transition like MacKenzie Dern's a a
good one that comes from Europe so
that's another thing too she's a good
example great Grappler you think she's
winning her fights but you know her last
like
um she fell in love with the Striking
yes like with the Chinese fighter I
don't have their name uh Jiang oh wait
wait no
um it's another one she she just she
lost it Carla but McKenzie she beat
McKenzie oh recently yeah she's a
Chinese fighter I forget her name but
her uh Marina Rodriguez you know
do you think like they were getting kind
of beat up like with the Jiu Jitsu but
they're striking and know how to use the
cage in wrestling they they beat
McKenzie so that's what I'm saying like
women's like fighting is still like
going it's progressing but um I feel
like they're still trying to catch up
because they don't know how to like
balance it'll get there yeah where's the
guys it's like you know because little
girls need they need Heroes like
yourself they need those like rose they
need people to look up to because they
see you guys sit in the path like oh
that's possible when before it was
impossible yeah you know but for those
of you that don't know who Daniel Kelly
is uh Casey play the freaking highlights
so people can educate themselves and I
know it's awkward to watch yourself but
these are pretty good highlights
and she was a Samba we're talking about
World Champ here yes
yes and then you transition to the back
choke her out yeah it's like an old
school one like a lot of uh I actually
learned this when I was like 12 like
when guys would just pulling my neck
from my guard
um and I'll just use that to like go
around transition and get to their back
yeah
you're all smiling
I obviously you know what's funny is I
don't uh I don't really smile on purpose
I think it's just my face it's just your
face that's a good thing at least you're
not frowning like maybe you know if I'm
trying to squeeze and my mouth's just
open like I don't really notice that I'm
smiling yeah it looks like you're
smiling then I look crazy well I am
crazy but I just look crazy that I do
but you'd rather have that than have
like a weird sad face yeah yeah
that's good we'll play the whole thing
for the fans of the and educate
themselves most of them already know who
you are but uh you have your big match
for us it's next Friday for you to be
Saturday because it's in Singapore which
is across the freaking planet yeah uh
tell me about your opponent you guys
have uh fought before
Jessica
yeah competed and she's a ibj FF uh gold
medalist yes
one world's recently so she's pretty
good
yeah yeah look at you yeah but that's
what I'm saying like now that jiu
jitsu's there there's a path to being a
professional like people have Europe
straight professional she's still
competing that where you don't have to
she's considered professionals no 100
she is especially if she's competing
against you and she's done before but
I'm just saying you don't have to go
that traditional route of winning those
other tournaments yeah back then it was
a big deal yeah 80cc yeah now like
people don't understand I mean mean I'm
just like I take her seriously like
you're a world champion like you're
beating girls who are like trying to get
the title like they worked hard for it
but it's like nowadays you know titles
don't really mean anything anymore like
you know I dream of girls who have
either placed in ADCC trials who've
fought girls who want who won uh World
Championships other promotions and they
beat them so I feel like nowadays like
people are so stuck on like well it's
still a big thing like it's a big deal
yeah legit like yeah you know that's
really awesome but you know I go into
this match I don't you know that's those
things don't really matter to me do you
do you ever feel like you need to check
those boxes in order to get validation
from the Jiu Jitsu Community or do you
even care
I don't really care if you go out and
choke her out and get that strap which
is you know what's funny five pounds or
17 pounds or something like that how
heavy he's the one Championship belt
it's too heavy lighting it up but
um I mean if you get that strap none of
that other stuff matters yeah no that's
that's why I've like been it's been so
focused for like for this camp for this
match and especially like you know in
writing she's more accomplished than me
so beating her and getting his title
with like basically you know check my
box like I'm the world champion good
yeah and it's in a cage I feel like
that's more like legit whereas you know
where and how I grew up in Jiu-Jitsu
like you're kind of like in the mat like
if you go out of bounds they reset you
either the same position or some
tournaments are different like they'll
reset you but make you stand back up and
give the other person points or however
like you reset it from the position
um but yeah this is this is pretty
exciting for me yeah hell yeah it is and
I think too being in one championship
and there's a title on the line it's
different where you're not gonna you
know sit on your butt scoot your butts
you don't want to win just off so I
actually said this before like yeah
people like the Casual person like
especially like casual MMA fans you know
when you're watching a jiu jitsu match
most times are probably like oh why are
they still sitting on their butt be like
just get up or this is boring but to
like a person like a hot Jujitsu
hobbyist or competitor you know they
understand what's going on so I feel
with how one Championship with these
matches they make you be more aggressive
they make you stand up go for a takedown
use the cage it makes it match exciting
yeah for the Casual whereas you know
other matches people don't really
understand what's going on but like me
and you kind of understand like what
they're trying to do the technique their
strategy yeah I get it but but I think
too like that's why one Championship
signed you I think that's why in the
position you're in I think that's why
Mikey uh mushumeshi is in the position
he's in yeah exactly otherwise it's
gonna be a tough sell man yeah it just
is like if they're just shooting their
butt and it's always you know decisions
if you watch like past matches uh I
believe it was the first US card um with
uh I'm probably gonna say his name wrong
Dan Ritter Ritter or something oh yeah
yeah
I was there for that you know a lot of
people like I thought Ty was just gonna
submit him he did really well against
him but just like certain strategies
that you know a strictly MMA guy who has
like basic decent Jiu Jitsu against a
really high level Jitsu guy like Tai and
his brother you know he was able to kind
of hold off a lot of submissions and
takedowns because because you're not
playing the game yeah and you're talking
like I'm not I don't want to say I
started that blueprint but I was in
metamoras and went against cyborg who's
just strictly Jiu Jitsu oh Jesus and I
had my black belt yeah I went against
Cyborg and he couldn't submit me I went
in his guard I did a lot he just because
I didn't play his game now for the
traditional Jiu Jitsu fan they hated it
so mad at me
that's the game like we can figure it
out like as long as you have some high
level understanding of Jiu Jitsu and
where the traps are you can be able to
figure it out yeah because you're not
playing the game yeah I learned that my
last match I did catch weight in
Thailand um under one and uh she it was
in the ring it wasn't in a cage but
um she really knew how to use the rules
and like the ring against me so it's
frustrating yeah I had a rude awakening
at one point but then I ended up beating
her so yeah Cyborg's dad came up to him
I was like what what is it you know he's
like what are you doing I was like sorry
man got paid yeah I guess it was a plan
not to get submitted around anymore
right no no that was fun though yeah the
same car as like me Mackenzie Dern that
was before she was fighting yeah oh well
that's yeah she's a little badass yeah
you're a black belt black belt yeah how
many degrees uh just one oh same yeah
yeah just one yeah yeah no yeah yeah
just one but uh with your opponent and
and she's aggressive too that's why it's
a good matchup you know that's why I
think because like Mikey came out I
think the week before he competed in
Denver and you know he ended up
submitting the guy and he's like you
know the pressure's on me to make this
exciting for the Casual fans and the
same pressure's on you not that there's
not pressure already but yeah there's
you know there's always pressure but I
feel like I mean I gotta do what I have
to do to win the match 100 I know she
like she's able to study my matches like
how I use the cage or the ring so you
know if I'm a little if I'm overly
aggressive she encountered that like
I've been studying her like every day so
I kind of you know if I really good Jiu
Jitsu person if I just leave anything
open she's gonna be able to like take it
so and and going back to your your roots
so your your parents dropped you off at
the Jiu Jitsu gym how'd this start so
like the suburbs
the Bible's like namington okay Bucks
County it's a really big area
um and brothers sisters I have two older
brothers so two older brothers you Mom
and Pop move out to Pennsylvania my
oldest brother lives in Florida like
gotcha he's like my half brother gotcha
my full brother um yeah he lived with me
okay Carry On
um and I so the school that I went to it
was from sixth grade to ninth grade it
was a big Junior High and
I started like one month in as being a
new kid I was getting bullied by like
the big girls who were like in eighth
grade and Ninth Grade the warlocks yeah
yeah
I was um
yeah I was probably like 65 70 pounds at
the time like I was
so small
I was yeah I was um yeah they're like
lockers and stuff huh were they like
shoving you in lockers uh no but you
know it came to a point where like you
know they were you know kids are mean
man yeah back no back then it was they
were mean I'd say it's worse now because
of social media so imagine you're
getting bullied at school and then on
coming home and then you're still
getting bullied so I feel like it's more
easier now than back then back then it
was brutal yeah
yeah it was it was a bad time for me
like I had bushy eyebrows like I always
got called caterpillars and
yeah it was bad caterpillar it was bad
but yeah these girls would follow me at
home sometimes and then I would be it
was to a point where I got scared to go
to school
and so did you tell your mom and dad
you're like I don't want to go yeah and
my mom like as crazy as she was like she
wanted to like visit the school and like
I'm like your mom yeah and but the thing
is like
you know you these parents you they can
do they try to like push the principles
or the school districts like hey my
kid's game bullied are you guys gonna do
something about they're not doing we can
only do so much you know yeah even the
prince was like yeah I don't she has to
stick up for herself but it's like these
nights it's like eighth graders and
ninth graders picking on a sixth grader
yeah it's not right
um so with long story short I I would
say like around October or November that
year in sixth grade I
I like came home one day I just remember
telling my dad like I don't want to go
to school anymore like I'm getting
bullied whatever and um my dad went on
Google like looked up like self-defense
schools because back then nobody knew
like Jiu Jitsu schools it was like Kung
Fu crap yes so I think that's what he
looked out he looked up another karate
school because I in Philly I did Karate
shout out to dad though I get it and
just Googling oh this is when we had the
Google Maps you just printed out and um
luckily it was it was called like
self-defense uh I'm not gonna say like
my old school's name but it was like a
self-defense school and my dad said like
I should go there you know check it out
and he wanted me to be involved in
something too like stay active and make
friends because I was a new kid so thank
you Dad
um then I uh my mom took me to that
school uh like that Friday
I just made it on time because like it
was still new because I can tell like
not many kids were signed up and like it
was like mixed it was like little the
little warriors with the junior Warriors
and some adults and this is all karate
at that time okay so when I walked in
um you know my my mom like I like a
really bad speech so I couldn't really
talk to my coach at the time so like my
mom explained to him like Hey like my
daughter is being bullied she's new
um is there you know can can we uh what
can you do yeah so he I originally
wanted to strike so that's why you know
I actually actually I went ahead of
myself before I looked up like who Gina
Carano was who uh a lot of these like
old like Fighters old school Fighters
like when I saw Forrest Griffith and the
other guys Stefan Bonner yes I saw that
first fight with my dad and that's how
like I started to get into this world
but I know anything about Jiu Jitsu all
I know was oh I want to do fighting
stuff yeah that's how I explained it and
you're in Philly which is known for
their you know
in boxing as well
Bernard Hopkins Eddie Alvarez actually
had a gym at the time called Fight
Factory it was like a good 10 minutes
from where I was training underground
Kings right up this yes right up the
street Eddie yeah Eddie's my boy so I
thought I was getting into that because
like I was like yeah like I want to
strike I kept saying Yeah I want to
start fighting because you want to punch
these warlocks yeah that's basically
what I said and then my coach at the
time was like all right uh let's get you
into Jiu Jitsu first and I decided like
what's Jujitsu and he basically
explained you know if you get to the
ground if some if these big girls ever
get you the ground you'll be able to
defend yourself and I was kind of like
stubborn I was like all right fine like
whatever got into my first Jiu Jitsu
class uh gear nogi I was in the ghee so
yes I was in the ghee
um I was really awkward I had sweatpants
on and the guitar so it was like my
child class yeah come on no um I was an
awkward kid I was wearing gray
sweatpants and I get a Big E top and the
first day he showed like a few
techniques showed me what an arm bar was
is whatever naked choke was and then put
me into the sparring class love it 15
minutes uh the last 15 minutes of it and
my first uh there was like one other
girl that was like kind of my size I was
like maybe a year older than her I
wrecked her like show cans and I just
did like basic all that anger yeah I did
like the basic you know pull the ghee
down yeah to go around the head I spun
around I don't even know how I knew this
which is crazy being that young yeah
that first day because like he showed me
like running I could choke so I just
think all right I get behind her back I
choked him right away so that's why I
did uh I pulled the collar down went
around behind her back choked her
um and I went against a boy he was like
my size or like he was a little bigger
took him down stayed him out and I just
remember our barring him and him ever
since that day I just fell in love with
it he loved it since then yeah and then
when you went home and then did you have
to use any of it against these warlocks
at a school
um not that year but the the in eighth
grade I had to yeah yeah what's up now
and how'd that go no um well you
thought but yeah the the Relentless well
if you fight their friend then their
friend like wants to fight you and then
it's the tournament basically yeah
pretty much but and then girls are just
barely they want to prove a point so but
I was able to like defend myself once
and I beat her but I got in trouble but
when my dad that day took me in Dunkin
Donuts they kind of like reward me so
here yeah your parents yeah right pants
are great yeah and then
um I went to like another new school
um sophomore year to senior year it was
like more like the rich area school and
those people are really mean like I had
like everyone I feel like every school I
went to like there was like a lot of
bullies or something it's tough just
being a new kid like you know it's like
the school so like I feel like the last
Abington was more like kids were more
aggressive and then you had the the new
school I went to they were just all like
the beach the beach are down here yes
yeah yeah and um actually I was in
junior it was my junior year I had to
take like a senior class
um because I guess like when I switched
schools I had to like take a higher
science class so I was in the science
class with like seniors and
I had like a little incident like that
day I remember because like this girl
kind of showed me in the bathroom like
why did you shove me and I was like this
awkward kid so like I was just looking
confused and she took it as like why are
you looking at me like that so she did
that and I kind of said like I just
defended myself like like Ferrari being
mean I was a kid so like it sounds
cringe now but I was just like why are
you have to be so mean and then her
friend thought I was like trying to pick
on her so then her friend followed me to
my science class that day because like I
was in a senior class so I guess like
she had friends there oh actually my
brother was in my class too and he
witnessed this whole thing
um
so but he didn't defend me because he
was really quiet and yeah he's really
shy yeah yeah um so that day like I
remember being science class and uh she
kept staring me down from the hallway
and I remember my science teacher had to
go out to like talk to someone or
something it was weird and um she walked
into my classroom and like right when
she put her bag down I like started just
I put my bag down and then I just
learned how to do a level change double
liked her and oh yeah started and nobody
messed with you after that no one did
nope and then yeah
it yeah so like you know especially like
with bullying um and like being where
I'm at right now like I want to like you
know I feel it's really important to
like I don't want my kids to be raised
or um whenever I have kids but you know
being absurd being that like
uncomfortable position where they don't
know if they should defend themselves or
not correct and you know I feel like
with a lot of bullying that's going on I
feel like
you know there might be in a tough
situation and
you know how they're going to defend
themselves we want to have the tools if
they don't want to be bullies but if
things don't wait for them to hit like
they're if they're bothering you like
shut that down yep it in the butt right
away and then move on with somebody else
oh just ignore them nope that doesn't
work that doesn't work trust me it
doesn't work yeah and I tried every tool
to like
a fight just because I learned
self-defense just because I I was
competing I didn't want to use it
because you know I even as a kid I knew
like what I could do because I felt like
I was more experienced obviously but
there's also a confidence you give out
for confidence to in the kitchen yeah
yeah think about it if you could uh talk
to your mama now it's like you go back
to that first class and you're in sweats
and a ghee top choking out you know and
you'd be like Mama a few years from now
and be World Champ she actually wanted
me to quit at one point because she felt
it was during a time where women weren't
you know they weren't making as much
money as the guys they're they weren't
getting as much of their respect and
attention I get it so I mean I
understand like where she was coming
from but and then did you go on to
college or right out of high school was
the past yeah I um I went to college
because my mom
I went to Community College in Philly
and then
of happened so I kind of just stopped
and
then I refocused into Jitsu and here I
am made the move yeah made the move it
was hard it's not the mama and pops are
starting in Jiu Jitsu yeah I know
they're not with us you know yeah we
don't have to talk about that but I'm
sure they're proud as [__] yeah yeah
yeah and come next Friday it's gonna be
a big deal for you oh yeah yeah can't
wait we're looking forward to your fight
next Friday it's on Amazon Prime one
Championship Jessica Khan you for the
world title from sweats and a ghee to a
freaking gold belt thank you for flying
all the way out here thank you yeah
appreciate it great kicks thank you yeah
those are dope thank you a lot of them
appreciate you on September 29th three
World titles are on the line in three
different sports one Epic night for
women's martial arts that fantix is
something else ham is a beast
two world champions it's insane it's
Insanity Here Comes Kelly that is Shia
awesomeness
one fight night 14. stamp vs Ham on
Prime video